well James Bond is one of the
longest-running movie franchises of all
time and there's a reason most guys want
to be James Bond he's the ultimate super
spy he's good with guns he's good with
martinis he's good with women that had
perverted names he's an all-star class
act and in the latest one we got Skyfall
which once again stars Daniel Craig as a
kind of different Bond one they tried to
dive a little bit more into the
psychological width and in this one he
is searching for a person who's trying
to take out his boss em which is pretty
handy seeing how he's already been
declared dead and thus he's already very
hard to find being a spy on top of it
also really helps Skyfall is one of the
most ambitious of the James Bond films
it has really good characters it has a
really good story it has decent action
just about everything about is engaging
except for one aspect James Bond
I never liked Daniel Craig as James Bond
I think he's up for nothing about him
ever did anything for me every time I
look at him he seems to have just one
expression and that's trying not to pass
a fart on elevator he never draws me in
now if you take out all the other James
Bond's if you take gala Pierce Brosnan
or Sean Connery a lot of the classic
bonds and the charm you say you want to
do something different with it that's
awesome my problem is that Daniel Craig
just doesn't draw you in he has one
expression he has one look and I just
don't find that engaging but everything
else in the film I think is really
really good as I said some very unique
characters a lot DS in action and
actually a story that you're really
drawn into and you want to know what's
gonna happen at the end so just based on
that criteria I'd say it's a pretty damn
good movie just try to ignore the main
character I know that sounds strange but
I did enjoy him wow are you off you're
an ass okay okay so your talk you
telling me that Daniel Craig is actually
like engaging and that he draws you in
well maybe not as engaging as George
Lazenby but you know I think he's like
Pierce Brosnan and uh and Sean Connery
is I mean these people had a charm and
there was a mystery people wanted to be
you know these James Bond who was one of
regional Bond they played that bond to
death okay but here's the thing if they
want to do do you think this one's like
more psychologically
interesting and he has like mental
issues and emotional issues and stuff
like that well you actually got to learn
about some of them in this movie versus
the other films but but just because
they tell you he has a backstory does
that mean that the character that he
himself actually pulls you in okay now
somebody coming from the line of thought
that the best Batman was Michael Keaton
who has four lines of dialogue in the
entire life but he sold those for life
he was mysterious you wanted to find out
more about he had expression in his face
he had emotion and he had and he had an
identity I never gotten identity out of
Daniel Craig the man is a trained killer
he's like a Navy SEAL you think those
people be really interesting what you
want him to go on freaking dr. Phil or
something and just you know explain his
entire backstory no but but what you
pointed out character wait what
character did Sean Connery have what
character oh he's just the the smooth
talker
I need no you're right what in terms of
heads feet then he likes I take arty
knees and he'll bang anything no no no I
don't need deep on saying that they're
gonna do it do it really dive into them
and get an actor who I admit it's not as
deep as like say Tom Cruise in the
Mission Impossible movies which well I'm
giving off James Bond but ya know that
this graduate should probably address
for this movie this movie steals from a
lot of our spy movies including itself
you know a mission and pod minnow
midgets kids got an oculus like Mission
Impossible the cons of a bond going
rogue is straight from license to kill
um there was a lot of Goldeneye in this
movie yeah there's pretty much it pretty
much plundered itself and everything
else in the spy genre but what what I
find most ironic about this whole thing
is have you noticed how the Mission
Impossible films have gone out of their
way to be like James Bond and then I'm
Taylor so James something is wrong
something yeah
yeah it's a more smarter yeah this is
more about like actual you know gasp in
a James Bond movie they're spying going
on if you have their phone I love you
there he's sitting there spying on the
you know like sharpshooter
and there's a NOC list and like this is
the first Bond film in a while where I'm
like oh so he's actually gonna do some
spying Oh got it that's awesome exactly
he's joking is this his real name
what's fun yeah I only I never got that
okay so that is one thing about the
movie is it it's a strange combination
of like we're going to make this smarter
but we're still going to give you dumb
bond because we've decided that we the
audience when it gets down to it will
you know be like yeah we want a smarter
bond but really they also want bond to
still kind of be the same kind of like
you know chain-smoking a hard-drinking
order man oh yeah man oh like who will
just waltz into anywhere and they're
like and what's your name Jake well I
were a supervillain if I'm a
supervillain arias BAM yeah yeah I'd be
sitting there Monte Carlo and I'd be
like oh that's that dude that all these
other guys for 20 years have been
talking about I blown away right there I
would take nitrates oh you'll say my on
the other there I have a problem with
bond in this movie and this actually
isn't even a great thing it Daniel great
thing is that he starts I don't think
I'm giving anything away he starts off
essentially dead you know like I like
you shot it we already heard yeah if you
can't figure he's coming back yeah I
think people know that James Bond isn't
gonna die at this for real but he's he's
shot and then you cut to Julie dead
doing a great job as am I need probably
this is the only film that I think knew
what the hell to do with Judi Dench when
they cast her in gold and I was like oh
that's brilliant you can do something
interesting they were kind of here they
do it as I think and here's the Sailor
but James Bond James Bond is shot he's
dead cut the Juliet Julie dead just go
through a lot of trouble cuz she made
the call and her job is on the line she
put a lot of people at risk
what the hell's James Bond - and he's
enjoy being dead he's like you know
sleeping with some you know chick under
a water so he went CG scorpions and
stuff like that it's like dude you could
have really died you know why did he
want to stay away I'm sure there's a
reason but they never really go into his
like I know I'd be dead I mean while
this woman's trying to sir she can to
keep her joke on the Gary he just cut
the end making out with some broad under
a waterfall the if money six killed him
that's why I didn't want to go back if
you work for an organization and you're
sitting there and your boss says hmm
well
he's sitting there on the train maybe we
can get this terrorist later now take
the shot
boom away get over there pretty quick
it's just like the shinies you hired
socked and gloom away and I fall 200
feet and go flying down the rapids and
show that you're my 3 by opening credits
sequence I'd like you know what I'm
taking that I I just think that's all
but in like the first five minutes I
mean to not say it's like you know but
you shot me yeah
okay I'm back boom they're just back and
then cuz if they didn't it literally
would have been brined accomplished
mission impossible but that's one say if
I can do it go all the way go with like
a psychological say they tap on it but
they never go also with license to kill
which are also ripping up so yeah the
film's well I yeah I say you're gonna do
this then I say keep it if you want the
James Bond fine make him funny don't
think I'm serious make it serious don't
try this it like your sense or the dumb
by which is fine we like don't bond you
know but we if we want to do the series
stuff let's go yeah okay here's your
problem
you're wrong and two if you try to make
them just funny well we've done that
before for 50 years
ya know if you guys I'll try something
else if you want to make them serious
they did that more in Casino Royale
everything but the bond I grew up with
that's just it's so different I can't is
summer I think there's a half and half
way where that's what it did in this
movie that's precisely what they did and
maybe if they got a stronger actor to
bring it across but until then we just
have this one face this one look that
never smiles never has fun which is fine
I'm sorry the shoes of guy who doesn't
smile and can stare you in the eye and
say I'm going to blow your fucking head
off and not have an emotion about it is
not hard and steely enough for you if he
doesn't are they doing artist Ely are
they doing like fragile and in say if
they want play bond as a psycho that's
awesome that's exactly what they did but
he's not interesting psycho he's a poor
little babe I'm gonna talk about
interesting psychos can we at least talk
about the villain the Batmobile is a ton
of fun and the ton of fun but I don't
know what it he's I don't know what's
his deal uh that that really is a mix
between like okay I thought much more
than very bad
more for every single character
including him and every cure but even a
queue was a more interesting
psychological study than bond in this
film q.q has our minds yeah you don't
wanna be solvent if you presume to than
just one from Daniel Greg okay
I like what they did with Q but I'll
tell you where I lost it when he's given
them first off what sort of organization
basically yeah first up what sort of
organization when you can meet in your
headquarters is like me to help you see
him yeah I was like we're gonna where we
gonna be at the Art Museum I know you're
like trying to hide out and everything
but what sort of spire miseries like no
I'm gonna give you your top-secret
equipment I've got it oh man yeah and
it's a gun every what do you think we're
gonna have an exploding pens yes I you
know at the climax when they're you know
blowing all these guys away trying to
break into the ocean and explode you
know I would have made life a little
easier here a fucking exploding pen just
set this down don't we would see a
common boom yeah I'm like you know like
the CIA really did use this stuff like
you look at like old Russian like
American CIA espionage they hit my
perfume in fake quarters and this isn't
unrealistic yeah it's not unrealistic to
expect that you know you could have your
exploding pen and by the way that was a
shot at Goldeneye because that was the
why no I was like and I'm like really
you they're really really good I like
going yeah that's like one of fast as I
was growing a house movie go so but but
what we're liking this way we're like in
this movie we can talk about how long no
no idea that something I mean it's it's
really good there there is some dumb and
there are a couple of cheap shots but I
really did give us the best Bond film
well I liked Casino Royale I know you
didn't I just like to see the more he's
a bar he what so sorry I don't want to
see people everything from other spy
thrillers that's my question when it
comes as James Bond just separates out
because it just defined the spy film
even though is goofy and over-the-top
what sets what separates this fight from
any other spy that we've seen in other
spy movies give me a what other great
one identity me are you tied Matt Damon
was great as his fight is trying to get
back
identity man did okay we're using Matt
Damon as the best not the benchmark but
I mean I thought that I thought you did
a pretty good job and I followed him but
I want to know what was going on with
him with this movie a lot I don't want
to know what was going on at that movie
I couldn't see anything every second
they're doing an action scene I'm having
a seizure like no idea what do you think
the act I thought was disa I didn't
think it was great I thought the action
was I thought the action was really good
I thought the interesting was in their
attempt to make it smarter the action
was more restrained there are a lot of
lies now and it's more spy base he my
favorite see he tails this sniper and he
just sits there watches like why does it
happen I know I'm like that's what you
know what that's but that's what a true
spy would do he's just like I don't know
what's going on here maybe I can
actually just watch this happen figure
what's going on and sneak in later you
just totally wasn't me other guy way I'm
like that's that's the spy game then the
robot oh yes cover just cuz you're like
oh there's some hot chick I'm into like
I'm gonna totally do I know he loves a
hot chick died too you remember by the
way ballon I was buried too by the way
audience if anybody named James Bond
comes up to you and says you should
totally betray your secret evil
organization I can protect you you're
done you're told you're on yeah I would
just turn and run try to apologize and
say this guy came to me I was it kill
him kill him cuz bond can't douche it
okay so we should wrap up your uh in
terms of what we thought about what
would you what would you uh I think
people know we like we we like the actor
we like a lot of characters in this I
like Daniel Craig well what did you
dislike what it's not so much things
that I disliked I liked them because
they were sort of old school dumb bond
so bringing in the bringing in the car
you know some of the dumb one liners
like they're dumb I do respect them but
they are dumb in the the whole bit at
the end word I mean they they try to
make judi dench badass and it works
gotta words I was gonna say I just it
gets almost just like comical we're like
they're trying to break into this place
if you don't tell the long yeah and
rigs yeah em rigs up this entire mansion
and it totally turns into home alone
where she's like sitting there like this
is Spy house I must protect it like I
want this your bless you like saying
grace over the macaroni cheese I dare
not that's this macaroni and cheese and
all who made it and anyone are you
fasting probably electric do you chance
give up are you thirsty for more come up
here to give me horses I sacrifice just
hilarious I think I suppose uh next
mouth spit off yeah and then there was
some dumb to like wit when they're
escaping and like M supposed to be the
head of mi6 and she's using a fucking
flashlight I'm like you're supposed to
you know like I don't understand like
dumb things like that and there are
certain throwbacks to the old bomb like
yeah the evil girl that he's gonna
protect that you know it's just like
sure whatever but it did lead to some
great lines the best waste good scotch
that was that was Albert dick line that
was a dick line but like I like scotch
and that was the first thing I thought
look I'm fine no nobody saying you care
more about the scotch than the main
character that that's always a good sign
uh okay so so mile I cared about bond
I'm just saying I cared about the Scotch
more than the bill that I do had a
target on her head from and that's a
good plan uh uh me personally I like
everything a lot like I said i couldnt
get into the bond but I will say he
didn't destroy it for me I didn't felt
like it totally brought the movie down I
just thought wouldn't this been a
perfect movie if they really did even
the traditional James Bond pretty did a
real good psychological study in step
hinting at it but yeah I I like I think
we can both think that we both really
enjoyed I own I mean for me Sam Mendes
would not have been my first choice but
they doing he would he would for
cinematography like this is like a
Stanley Kubrick film all of these shots
are gorgeously composed the action which
I wouldn't have expected is actually
really good the CGI is limited it's
there but it's not in-your-face that
scorpion look pretty like yeah that
Scorpio is ridiculous aside from that
aside from the two second CG scorpion it
looks pretty yeah and it's the smartest
Bond film I've seen since
I'd say Casino Royale and gold and I
unlike Casino Royale which I think was
going more hardcore this one was trying
to combine
Casino Royale with gold and I it works
he's a little derivative sure but you're
watching James Bond you're always going
to get derivative fighting it's not
gonna you're not almost I'm gonna get
Citizen Kane out of this thing like so I
would say just go in and enjoy it and I
like Daniel Craig you're wrong I think
we can both agree though India more
ballbusting uh no I was okay without the
testicle Archer well dad did that weapon
the saving grace for me if Daniel Craig
eyes balls busted I would have liked it
a lot more I think needs more Judi Dench
throwing paint cans down at people
trying to break it let's make this movie
Daniel Craig game ball busting Judy
Dench throwing throwing the ball busting
thing from the top of the stairs hitting
him in the nagas I got one more better
thing as long as we read it since it's
called Skyfall it's a reference to like
Scotland um all I could think of what
thing go up there it's a grey its dank
and I'm like dude this totally looks
like Skyrim we need some dragons we
totally got a getting's dragon versus
dragons and a Judi dent with paid cash
James Bond baseball is the Dragonborn I
like let's make this movie let's do it
thank you so much for watching this is
super lame rivalry take it I win
you